in this episode okay Ken boy what you
thinking and I oh god oh god [ __ ] me
right right see now ah thanks
Hey Oh the super speed being gone messes
with me uh look I'm playing slow motion
yeah Bob [ __ ] you guys
Oh God not this max man Oh No Oh what do
they do
what'd I do what is go every go now
please I'm still back somewhere no oh my
god I nearly hit what are you still
wired oh god don't shoot me with the
Rockets um I'll get it now see what
happens with it so fast yeah no that's
what you get that's what you get Nova oh
man that was written upon Ken we're not
against each other
yes who did I kill did I kill sorry yeah
I think you killed Beauty food what did
you can me really what did you come oh
my quality food oh my god oh god that no
my hate yep what damage okay yes how
dare you oh my god I'm so offended right
yeah okay how you guys won dear
literally the oh yeah those rocket Anita
shootin Tex
oh you gotta because you can't lick it
huh I don't know if I got it you got it
yeah I believe it too yeah no it's gonna
get to be Doc John what are you even
doing make the shortcut do it yes kid oh
my god
sorry okay are you forgot the keyboard
dock chef forty boy can you're playing
on a keyboard no yeah whoa [ __ ] a
rocket man
everybody tighter and tighter that was a
tough one guys what you died why am I
always in the back when the [ __ ]
rockets hit man
did you just one it's always it's
bullying its rocket bully I'm okay with
it though I like it no oh my god hey
wait up the cool kid come in no yeah
you'll never put a cookie it'll be
awesome can never be in the cool kids
club I'm a cool kid Oh
raisin [ __ ] ass not dead yet I'm away
my boy [ __ ] you nope [ __ ] yo no no I
hate you oh why you gotta be so rude
oh [ __ ] I look at you yeah [ __ ] in
[ __ ] itches [ __ ] okay is fine now
it's cool it's cool it's cold we're cool
right yeah you and your [ __ ] what
that an exploit what just happened to
you wasn't
but sometimes fine it's fine well you
can have all no I like it though I like
it all right yeah I like it done up I
love them up n by priority got to make
sure Ken doesn't win yay oh I thought he
got me don't you ma'am from me I'm
friendly I listen there's but there
that's what the okay jump duck jump I'm
sorry for cursing at you mark that's
okay
I didn't mean it I sweat out Ken for
dinner
are you keep Anna doing that [ __ ]
exploit oh I just try to take the
shortcut so that shortcut I gotta start
doing the [ __ ] shortcoming it's
really hard to do it very easy to mess
up yeah it's over it's over it's over
getting brackets nope jump pro duck
oh well if Mark wins this then you both
won twice oh I don't know what I feel
about don't you [ __ ] you in your Rockets
whoa oh I get strong now we can have fun
yeah get a ruin everything okay
chickens GM yes what the [ __ ] is this
road I went a shortcut I made you [ __ ]
take why
dovie's yelling win you like it that's
mad alright
Nova why are you not winning Oh Oh God
not the shortcut stop with the doctor
look first to win [ __ ] horses oh you
guys good ass [ __ ] don't win oh
god what is this well don't put that on
me don't put that on me please what do
you weigh Oh duck oh wow I'm not trying
good it Oh that screws me over so much
[ __ ] you and your [ __ ] suing No oh
[ __ ] you you had one job
Oh everyone what a match yet I didn't
dare oh that takes so much pressure off
you have one now yeah hi uh what do we
do what X stuff no um random Jesus
Christ although I don't feel like I need
to tone it down a bit I'm sorry I love
you guys I would get really a feeling
only if I win I love you ah you saw the
same I swear to God Rockets Oh oh god
what is that
Oh a missile Paco what does that mean
this was raining down from ona it's God
forsaken map again port yeah Wow
how do you do this shortcut I want to do
the trap how God is it's like 50% chance
of death whenever you do it
oh okay um you go up here you jump up
icon you watch it you jump right here oh
my god okay Oh Nova's gonna win a
probably that was worth it
thank you oh oh no Jesus Christ knocking
man what's this [ __ ] you like boxes
though Oh tell me all about the box
hahaha
I was amazing oh gosh I thought it was a
duck oh dang it through this that is a
close one
oh Ken don't can can boy I know what you
thinking and they oh god oh god [ __ ] me
ha ha ha that was good
let's go I got super lag in the
beginning Oh Oh appreciate it no oh
that's what you get for using that
that's a douchey thing to use Oh
MLG oh hell do son oh how about this say
let's say house guys wait wait up please
cuz I don't know okay well so my game
sanic don't know oh no power sanic iz
camming hmm no one does this shortcut
anymore no no I I'm so alive yes yes it
exists natural art [ __ ] you know how I'm
hope you still alive
I am I'm not good he has to grab ya
master crap I repeat ah thanks
ah can you can Donnie's a grapple by the
way if you duck way I know I know
forgot about it it's really hard though
yeah especially on highly oh [ __ ] manage
or cut it okay that no one I got it I
got it I got it got it I got it got
these cut touch I didn't believe you
I believe it a well done it's my Swedish
gosh yeah that's fair it's really fair
thanks game preciate it
yeah I'll be up here from know tell me
all about the boxes I mean oh hey mother
sorry mother mother of God why please
I'm like right at the edge please no
shortcuts
Oh [ __ ] died again now god damn it oh
my god it's raining banks oh come on we
it's real why did I grapple into the air
don't foul me cuz I'm friendly and nice
and you should get to know me first
before you take me out on a date
oh the same god dammit where do you get
their speed you son of a [ __ ] huh you
just had you just had to know a shortcut
master yeah I'm playing it safe man
cuz [ __ ] my ass that but like flick oh
yeah one oh come on I don't know got a
manually pick cuz those are why they
were gonna be things worried done uh we
are did the DJ one with this one library
give me Gennaro Desai I mean in every
road prototype good prototype yeah about
that anything but Rockets please yeah no
right no no god she's shaken rocket no
I should turn the Rockets off geez yeah
here we go can join I didn't think good
pick it for us this is why it's is why
he's winning oh my god I've never let
him host he's enabled hacks it's not
cool not cool
don't shoot don't what the [ __ ] are you
doing oh I'm mad
now ow all three yes all three did
mohawk yeah I don't need more to betray
your bone rocky what you hit me Oh a my
only friend you were my rocket to the
end I'd with that song right now it's
cold I'll get to the end thanks for
thanks for thanks for doing that
appreciate it am I still alive yes oh
that shortcut I know I am so pro please
oh my god like [ __ ] [ __ ] so bad girl
is so unfair sometimes it's ridiculous
oh god oh god no no
oh my god on its way
oh wow good Rockets Jesus oh [ __ ] it's
so much Seuss oh my god that just
wrecked everybody [ __ ] Rock jerk it
no don't short give me more all those
shortcuts you're like oh no don't shoot
the Rockets oh yeah that's good rocket
yeah let's take a truce on the Rockets
please
truly what Wow as always I'm doing a
taste of all the truths did not last
very long
oh we you did him a favor mark I did not
know those yes you did
I don't know if you remember that's
actually [ __ ] ladies yeah yeah that's
me
it's not like I might be late why can't
we just fight ken like that [ __ ] you can
I did it ah [ __ ] you [ __ ] I'll wait for
you problem is I'll let you win again
[ __ ] sake this partisan Kudo Oh stay
away
I'm coming just wait out why what yeah
no but wait for it we Scout okay oh
please type time handsome rocket though
yeah I do you want I know do you want
some wreck oh they're free oh my god
please want them rockets no stop how
many do you just go just go dis coward
wait go away No Oh Oh God alright
oh yeah
myself oh you do there that one oh my
god dad get this oh my god I'm coming
please cuz I haven't been yeah yeah oh
no oh god no oh God for me mark because
I waited for you okay I'll wait one last
time
uh here's a jogger a true general do
this
Oh God oh oh god oh god AB right can you
wait for me again oh I bet I wish I was
with you mark come on hey no pain again
can't maybe do it can made you do it
yeah oh excuse you get to open area
rockets fly yeah pretty much
are you still alive because I love you
and I want to marry you any that does oh
my god oh is that how you answer to a
proposal and she says never just ain't
never been stopped oh sorry Joe give
this video a like or become a bike how
hunger strike no one cares
brofist